all right so we are about to do your
first official water divination test so
I just want you to focus your attention
onto the leaf in the middle what an
affinity will you be an enhancer an
emitter perhaps a conjurer wait look
something is happening the leaf is
morphing and it turns out that you are a
subscriber which means that your
affinity demands that you immediately
press that gorgeous red button to
receive regular Hunt unto content upload
it straight into YouTube feed hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today I want to talk about that
thing that I almost always talk about
which is hunter hunter except that this
time around I'd like to examine the
seedy underbelly of the series being
some of the worst inabilities ever
created and I want to do this because
nen is a fantastic power system which I
generally praise to no end however this
does not mean that the use of net in the
series has always been perfect creative
or even interesting on a very basic
level so today we are here to expose
these less than compelling existences
however I do have a couple of things to
make clear before we do begin which is
that I really really need to emphasize
that this is a list of the worst in
abilities and not the worst of end users
I know that sometimes those two things
can be difficult to distinguish and to
be fair nen is a very personal
expression but this list is going to be
aiming to have as little to do with the
users as possible and in fact I already
have a list of the top five Western
users link in the description below if
you have gain this is not that this is
about abilities and these abilities are
going to be examined with the following
criteria in mind potency versatility and
ease of invocation
because nen is not straightforward and
the best abilities in the series in my
opinion are able to achieve all three of
these while the worst are often lacking
in at least two of those areas and one
more criteria I am adding to this
examination is that I am instantly going
to eliminate any nobility that consists
of some form of aura blast and an
example of an aura blast would be
rebuilt in Heaven's arena who used it to
boost his wheelchair while the Chimera
ant cluster whose ability was simply to
produce many many small aura blasts in
order to mimic gunfire and my reasoning
is because or a blast just far too
generic and generally far too boring
unless it being performed by xenos optic
of course who is an undisputed boss but
to be honest if I didn't ignore them
then or a blast would fill the top 5
immediately and probably even the top 10
so this is for the best and finally all
nine abilities on this list here today
must be Canon because I really have no
desire to explore many of the non-canon
underwhelming inabilities but with that
out of the way let's begin welcome to
the top five worst in abilities in
Hunter hunter number five our baingan is
NaN exorcism commencing our exploration
here today I cannot help but begin with
nen exorcism in general because this has
always struck me as one of the most
niche and less than versatile abilities
to have ever developed in this world the
weird thing about nan to think about in
retrospect is that it is still a greatly
kept secret from the world at large so
the percentage of people in need of an
exorcism is so ridiculously well I mean
the hunter Association largest
concentration of global nen users has
under 700 members so this world at most
surely only has a couple of thousand of
men users who actually understand what
they're doing and maybe a few thousand
Moloch emoji who invoke it unknowingly
and to add to this nen curses themselves
which the exorcism spells are also a
particularly niche practice thereby
lowering the need for them even more the
series itself has very
disproportionately represented the
amount of nan curses that one is likely
to encounter in this world but even once
an exorcist is found to charge here is
the real kicker once they remove said
that curse they effectively replace it
with another curse only this time it
affects the Exorcist themself so in the
case of mr. herb and Gani once he
removes a curse he then needs to conjure
an n beast the size of which is roughly
equal to the power of the curse and in
the case of dispelling Kenter his
countdown ability it resulted in a
massive symbiotic creature coming into
up and on his life which would only go
away once he had fulfilled the original
conditions of the curse and given what
happened in the gantry situation I don't
even want to know what our bengaii had
to take on board to remove crop occurs
curse from crawler and yes there are
other new Nexus in the serious one of
which is Hina who is a specialist whose
belly bloats in direct correlation to
the power of the coast removed but I'm
big on ease exorcism style is by far the
least appealing to me and to be honest
the only reason why doesn't appear
further down this list is because due to
the priority of the power he could make
a ton of money helping any afflicted nen
user and of course the exorcism can also
be used to remove curses placed on a
legate himself so it is far from useless
but it requires such a specific
situation and has little to no
versatility outside of said situation so
here it appears today
number four Bennett's Scissorhands so
here is a nice
weird and unique yet I would say heavily
undesirable and an ability which
undoubtedly evolved from Bennett's hobby
of brutal murder
essentially what Scissorhands does is
put forward two conditions for its
activation the first is that Bennett
must cut his targets hair off with his
favorite scissors and the second is that
Bennett then needs to consume the
targets hair and as a result Vinod will
then automatically be granted with the
wealth of physical information and it's
actually quite hard to say how vague or
specific this information is although in
the series be not used it and was able
to discover how old Biscay actually was
as well as achieve an accurate measure
for strength say you know that is
actually pretty useful in certain cases
because being able to measure the
strength of others is pretty invaluable
information especially in a knee
unrelated battle whilst if this ability
were to be applied elsewhere perhaps in
the field of medicine for example a user
of Scissorhands might be able to
identify exact physical afflictions of
certain patients and perhaps even
detailed internal information that would
infinitely speed up a treatment process
however this ability is just so so
strange and weirdly restrictive
primarily because it has to be performed
with Bennett's favorite scissors no
other kinds of scissors will work so all
one really has to do to counter this
ability if they so chose to do so would
to be to remove the scissors from play
however this power is also subject to
very simple and stupid things like
forgetting or even losing the scissors
so it does become very difficult to
justify and just like the next example
the ability only holds exceptionally
nice use and once again it just isn't
versatile enough to deal with even the
lowest of curveballs that could be
thrown your way I mean for example what
if your target is ball I mean I suppose
it doesn't specify where the hair needs
to come from one would assume the target
said but then again you've call so find
yourself needing to ingest the pubic
hair of someone else just to make use of
this ability and look know just know and
as such almost every other ability in
the series is far more appealing than
Scissorhands
number three porcupines needling body
hairs so I'm sure this is actually a
pretty memorable one for a character who
barely appears in hunt hunter but this
ability made me quite uncomfortable when
I first saw it because just thinking
about getting stuck in a mess like
kuvakin did is incredibly undesirable to
say the least
what does interest me though is a
porcupine is allegedly a natural
transmuter which is fascinating because
the needling body has would appear to be
more akin to a traditional enhancement
ability I mean at the moment we don't
actually know what brands
I used to bring it to life but given his
natural affinity I would say it is
entirely possible
the porcupine transmute scizor into hair
and then manipulates it from there
although that might be a bit of a
stretch because transmutation and
manipulation on direct opposites on the
nen ring but then again it has to be
some sort of manipulation right
otherwise how much does he control the
head and if it is then well porcupine is
actually a pretty damn competent and
end-user but the resulting ability is
still a bit mad any case I'm getting
bogged down in technicality Siras per
usual but really as powerful as these
hairs can become I really do not rate
this an inability at all it really only
has one purpose which is a surprise
attack sure in combat in something of a
permanent defense the problem is that on
their own
the needling hairs aren't all that
useful once porcupine has unleashed his
power he's very much done and relies on
someone else to finish the job most he
has maybe very weirdly incapacitated his
opponent sort of so yet again we find
ourselves needing an overly specific
condition to make decent use of this
power and that's why I have dumped the
needling body hair at number 3 here
today number 2 squalus dog manipulation
so before we get started here might I
just say that I personally love
disability and squalor prior to his
untimely death was very much living the
dream of having a pack a very
cooperative dogs with his sole purpose
in life being to take good care of them
in exchange for their services now with
all of that said when this ability is
considered within the greater context of
the hunter hunter world I just can't
really bring myself to replace it on
this list with almost anything else I
can think of the big thing I will give
dog manipulation is that it is indeed
versatile unlike most powers we've
explored and the dogs can perform an
incredible array of mundane life tasks
which would admittedly be nice but the
fact that it requires roughly a billion
dollars to be useful is a big
restriction it's not easy to invoke and
also in order to keep it active you need
to effectively dedicate yourself full
time to caring for the dogs which may or
may not be appealing to some so being
able to just use this ability at all
really does require one hell of a
sacrifice but my final point for placing
dog manipulation here is that a lot of
this is possible without the use of net
dogs can do absolutely phenomenal things
in real life after investing probably an
equal amount of time into training them
as squalor does into taking care of them
I mean no you can't send them on spying
missions and it's very very rare to have
them pushing in a serving cart full of
delicious dinners but a lot of this
is possible without nen and so as much
as I love it koalas dog manipulation
almost certainly belongs here however
there is still at least one ability that
I would rate or lower than it number one
or omits feather blades Oh Rahman to you
foolish funny bird thing so here is an
incredibly simple ability for a very
simple ant which is that remarkable uses
or to transform his feathers into blades
and yeah that's kind of pretty much it
dia boring if you ask me but at the same
time I will give remote a shred of
credit in this matter because to be fair
he is a natural enhancer so the fact
that he was able to do something
anything that wasn't a basic invocation
of nen is laudable but at the same time
he is still pretty incredibly
underwhelming and the main problem I
guess I have with Vermont is that he has
restricted this phenomenon to his
feathers rather than anything else that
could have been enhanced like perhaps
his hair toenails or even his strange
bird whisker things but here's the thing
at least when we were discussing
porcupine that power allows him to
control all of his body here rather than
just a select segment of his arms making
his ability somehow much more versatile
than remotes by default and look maybe
it's not fair to judge remote based on
his mere a few days of life that we are
going to anyway because that is the
exact point of this list and fed the
blades simply do not quite cut it no
matter what excuse you make for them and
I really don't know what else to say
about feather blades that's just how
many are and you might initially think
that this is remote Sansa to not being
able to pick up actual blades because he
has wings for arms but he actually
doesn't really he has arms covered with
feathers that would be a much more
accurate way of putting it
so he is perfectly capable of handling
just about anything he wants
the only thing it really has going in
its favor is that it is easy to invoke
but it's not particularly versatile or
particularly powerful so look feather
blades until proven otherwise is going
to be crowned the victor of this list
here today with the incredibly appealing
title of the worst nobility in the
series but what do you guys think please
do leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you're keen from all hunt
on to content and please do go and check
out some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel a regular hunt
on to glory delivered straight into your
YouTube feed but for now this has been
the new alter of you and I'll see you
next time